take a look back down las vegas history
as we
go for this week's edition of sin city
chronicles yeah jc's got all the fun tv
teams for you check it out
all right it's time for this week's sin
city chronicles a weekly
look back at vegas history in happenings
legends in concert has been part of the
strip
for almost 40 years the show debuted on
may 5th
1983 at the imperial palace the show
features
endless tributes to the likes of prince
rod stewart
elvis tina turner cher madonna kenny
rogers
the list goes on legends is set to
return may 27th
at the tropicana now a year later we had
another big arrival it's a street full
of fun
it's a street full of songs we're
talking about
big bird may 3rd 1984 sesame street live
made their first appearance at the
thomas and mack the sesame
jamboree it was sold out six nights
straight
cher she began her three-year residency
at caesar's palace on may 6
2008 she performed 200 shows in total
and was reportedly paid 300 million
dollars
this was her second residency at caesars
her first ran from 1979
to 1982 and she earned 300 000
a week the venetian opened may 3rd 1999
the hotel cost 1.5 billion dollars to
build
and sophia loren hosted the opening
ceremonies
now the venetian is on the land that was
home to the sands hotel
which was home to the rat pack here's a
cool fact remember this iconic photo
we have frank dean sammy peter and joey
standing outside of the sands
well there's a plaque outside marking
the exact location of that photo outside
the venetian
the footprints mark the uh the
approximate location
where the legends stood it is so cool
look at that
all right let's end things with a
blockbuster concert
[Music]
may 6 1992 van halen rother
for a lawful carnal knowledge tour to
the thomas and mack
this was the band's fifth las vegas
concert
so the question is this week do you
prefer van halen
or van hagar my answer i'll take them
both
all right that's your sin city
chronicles for the first week of may